foreign
.com I'm going to read the headline in
my own way because this is a
family-friendly show data shows the rent
is still too dang high oh yeah it says
the average American household is now
considered rent burden with a record
share of renters spending more than 30
percent of income on rent each month
this is a painful surge for many coming
coming at a time when inflation has
driven up the cost of food and energy
costs credit card debt is rising
spending is falling and there's a shift
in spending to more necessary items
rather than luxury type purchases well
that's that's good that's a good thing
but rents are sticky they are likely to
climb much further they're not they
aren't likely they aren't likely oh gosh
thank God that's good but don't expect
them to fall much from where they are
now and of course the surge in home
prices in the housing market has pushed
this number up and you know inflation's
applying demand a lot of factors here
but at the end of the day it's just a
lot of fresh frustrated everyday people
going like this is insane my rent went
up you know another 600 bucks and I
can't do anything about it so we wanted
to give you guys some practical things
you can do there's no magic trick here
there's no Silver Bullet I'm not going
to give you some life hack these are all
things that take compromise sacrifice
they're not fun but it will put you in a
better financial situation yeah and and
we just empathize because we got team
members here who've had to move because
it's like all of a sudden their landlord
raised their rent or their apartment
complex raised their rent 400 600 which
that's a lot even for somebody who's
budgeting who's living on a budget and
being disciplined with their money it's
it's pretty painful to see those numbers
but we do want to give you hope because
there are strategies around that yeah I
mean right here where our headquarters
is Franklin Tennessee Williamson County
I think it's the 10th or 11th wealthiest
County in the nation and so if you work
in this area it's hard to live in this
area and Dave always jokes about when he
was a kid you know he lived on the other
side of the tracks miles away going like
oh well that's where the rich people
live and you know cost of living is a
real issue and a lot of people who live
on the coast if you live in the Bay Area
or you live in New York or Boston or New
Jersey you feel this pain when you're
not making 300 000 as someone who works
at Google or someone who just got laid
off from Google more likely and you're
going what do I do when I make Thirty
forty fifty thousand dollars and I still
have this crazy high rent well in some
people kind of just close their eyes and
they kind of make the the excuse that
like there's no other option or the I
mean I I hesitate to say excuse because
it's like I feel for y'all and I feel
for people in this situation but the
option is not to stick your head in the
sand and go well I got to spend 50 of my
income on rent because it's like that
has very long-term consequences so we
want you to be super strategic and
really think through you know even
though this is crazy and the market is
crazy and it's unfortunate like what can
we do so for starters if you are single
this is especially hard for you because
you don't have you know the possibility
of dual income where you have both
spouses working which really helps cover
that rent number and so you might need
to go get a roommate and do that in a
safe way of course vet people through
Facebook communities mutual friends and
see if you can cut all of your expenses
in half by doing that I know it's not
fun if you're a grown adult to try to
get a roommate in your late 20s 30s even
40s is hard and it feels awkward but if
it cuts your expenses in half and allows
you to pay off debt and build wealth
then it's worth it for a season yeah and
another thing is to shop around so one
if you cannot be in a hurry when you
need to move that's great if you can
give yourself a little bit of Runway if
you know that your lease is going to be
up in four months or even in two months
and that your landlord May raise your
rent start thinking about that right
right now and start thinking about you
know are there other places in the area
and do your research so we actually sold
our house last year and we decided we
wanted to rent for you know a bit while
we moved down here and kind of figured
out where we wanted to live and I
shopped around like crazy and I'm gonna
be real honest y'all the rent deal we
found was Bonkers but I I largely think
it was because I kind of got
pretty obsessed with the like research
process and now I look at the cost and
I'm like that is actually crazy so you
know look for those Diamonds in the
Rough don't just go you know I like this
glamorous complex that has this really
cool pool the granite countertops the
hardwood floors it's been renovated that
may be out of the budget right now right
and you make it a way better deal down
the street for somewhere that's still
really great but just way more in your
budget and the other thing is go further
down the street literally further out of
the expensive areas and yes there may be
somewhat of a commute instead of a 15
minute and maybe 30 minutes but that's
worth it if you can save 400 bucks a
month and the other piece of this is a
lot of people are now working remotely
so if you're one of those people you
have the opportunity to live anywhere
let me remind you and while it's ideal
to live in downtown Manhattan it may be
more ideal financially to be further out
in Astoria George I'm hesitant for you
to say that because I'm like that means
more people are going to come to
Tennessee come on down hey they're going
to be here anyways not because oh man
our costs an hour
you live here so we're like I'm going
further out but there are things you can
do and again none of these are like
ideal silver bullets and hopefully the
market comes back down and cools off a
little bit and we'll slowly see those
rent prices come down but for now we
also can go make more income and so if
you are making 30 and you feel like
you've been in this thing too long you
should be making more go apply for those
new jobs sharpen up the resume our
friend Ken Coleman has some great
resources at his website Ken coleman.com
to help you with that but if you can
make 50 instead of 30 well that changes
the numbers now and we can breathe
and lastly getting out of debt will help
you breathe when it comes to affording
your rent one of the reasons rent feels
so crazily high is because you also have
700 800 in payments on this side because
of your student loans your car payments
the credit card payments the personal
loans it all adds up well and just
really making sure that you're buckling
down on your budget like I've we're
pretty intense with our budget but we've
been doing this no spend month and it's
been crazy looking at the numbers of how
much we saved like we thought we were
pretty tight on our budget and at the
end of the month we are saving so much
money like we thought we couldn't eat on
a hundred dollars a week and we did it
and we found all these other ways to
save so it's like even if you are on a
budget like really evaluate it deeply
and see if there's anywhere else you can
cut so that you have a little bit of
breathing room and that's a great
reminder Christina our parameters as far
as rent or mortgage goes is no more than
25 of your after-tax income and so that
if that's you and you're doing the
numbers you're going my rent is 1500
bucks and I take home three grand well
that's fifty percent of your income
being eaten up it's going to be hard to
live and to build wealth and to save and
to pay off that debt and to put food on
the table to put eggs on the table when
that much of your life is being eaten up
by the rent and so it you've we've got
to find a solution and go all right we
need a roommate we need to move further
out and we need to get on a budget and
so you can jump onto every dollar that's
our budgeting tool you can use it for
free and start to Crunch these numbers
and figure out where we can shave some
expenses how can we figure out how to
afford the expenses we really need and
figure out what the needs are versus the
wants and we want the nice apartment but
that might be down the line once we're
out of debt and we increase our income
and maybe one day we won't have that
pesky roommate leaving the dishes in the
sink
that's a tough one for me Christina now
that is I'm glad I have a roommate now
and it's my wife best roommate I've ever
had
gosh no more dudes just the dudes get it
together guys